Nikki Glaser and Gleb seven kinko we're
the first to get the boot on Dancing
with the Stars they are going going gone
and kept here's a question I never
thought I would be asking how will honey
boo boo fare in the ballroom better what
HP on lines learns Eva found out as they
announced the cast of Dancing with the
Stars jr. in one word describe honey boo
boo on Dancing with the Stars fabulous
like in my body what these kids like in
height they definitely make up in
personality
we also learned your nickname tonight
tell me it again it's already on party
because that party's already there are
familiar faces like a now 13-year old
reality star honey boo boo we know that
your mom was so by your side through all
of this show like how much did her look
what does that face man she's maybe a
kid been embarrassing maybe I mean
you're no stranger to TV working on
blackish did you balance it all I've
been filming blackish almost all season
that's pretty crazy did you get any
sleep
no but it will be Pro Brandon Armstrong
who will need the biggest break after
mentoring his two firecrackers a venture
star Ariana Greenblatt and partner Artie
on yeah I can't even and they're already
playing matchmaker and the both single
it wouldn't be the first time people
found love on Dancing with the Stars and
Dancing with the Stars juniors premieres
October 7th
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]